Hi, Taye.
What's happening?
How are you?
I'm wonderful, and I actually was reading this
with my daughters last night.
Are you serious?
Oh, come on, that makes me feel very, very good.
Thank you so much.
We'll talk about it in a little bit
with a friend of the show who's very special to us,
but I just, I had to tell you right away
that we were all in our beds,
cozy, snugs as bugs in rugs
reading your beautiful new book.
That's something else, I really appreciate that.
You have no idea how that makes me feel, that's good stuff.
Reading about you, your son is such a priority
in your life, and it felt really nice for me
to be reading about your life with him
because I'm in it with my two girls,
and, you know, the world is such a unique place right now,
as far as homeschool, and them not being able
to be around their friends,
and, you know, none of us have much of a life
outside of the life we have within our homes.
This is true.
Yeah, it's crazy, it's crazy,
and, you know, I hate to sound like a broken record,
but, you know, it's during these times
where I just remind myself, you know,
kind of how lucky I am, how lucky we both are.
You know, even though the world around us seems
to be, you know, spinning all different kinds of directions,
I do get to spend more time with him,
Walker, he's 11 years old,
and, you know, through the books that I've written
and even the television program "All American,"
we get to discuss, you know, all of these issues together,
and in a way where I'm comfortable
and where he's comfortable, do you know?
During these last few months,
we've been able to kinda connect
on a lot of, you know, really important subject matter,
and I'm kind of grateful for that.
Something that I was wondering if it's true,
because I've already visualized it
and romanticized it in the cutest way ever,
that you two have a thing called night swims.
Ah, yeah.
Yeah, that was cute at the beginning,
the beginning.
(Drew laughs)
(Taye laughs)
Now, I'm like,
ah, do I gotta get in the water too, man?
(Drew laughs)
But, yeah, yeah, yeah,
we're lucky enough to have a pool,
and, for whatever reason, you know,
because we were spending so much time together
in the pandemic, swimming at night never occurred to us,
and then, one night, he just asked,
and I said yes, and we both got in,
and it was under the stars,
and, all of a sudden,
we just started just really kicking it with each other,
talking, and I could just tell that he was maturing,
and it was a really great moment
that I don't know, you know,
that we would've had, you know,
were we not right there
in that specific, you know, area, time.
So, when he started opening up,
you know, inside, I was so excited,
and just had to pretend, you know,
like I was a cool dad just listening,
but I was so grateful, so grateful,
and I continue to be.
I really loved hearing that.
Excellent, I'm glad you can appreciate that.
I really can, and I appreciate all
that you've done in your life.
I mean.
Well,
I've done so much, Drew.
The theater.
Well, you have.
Your theater career is so impressive.
Well, thank you.
Reading about your hesitancy to even go
and meet for "Rent,"
and then it changed your life in many ways.
Yeah, it was crazy, it's crazy.
I just turned 50, and I'm saying all this stuff
that I had promised myself I would never say
when I was younger, all these cliches, you know.
I used to hate when people said, you know,
it's a gift that keeps on giving.
Well, "Rent" is literally the gift that keeps on giving.
When someone just asks me, you know,
what it has meant, what it means to me,
and it's so much, you know,
I met my baby mama there,
it's the beginning of my career,
and even today, you know,
we're still getting together,
and kind of moving people, you know, over Zoom,
doing Zoom, you know, charity concerts and whatnot.
It's kind of where it all started,
and it's nice, you know,
to know that it's continuing, you know what I mean?
None of us knew, you know what I mean?
None of us knew.
And even Walker's mother, Idina,
you know, Idina Menzel,
it's been really great.
I love the fact that I was there at the beginning.
You know, she made history in that show,
and continues to make history
with her singing and whatnot,
and to know that I was right there,
I loved sharing that, you know, with my son.
Like, Daddy was there when the world first listened to her,
so that's cool as well.
Wow.
(Taye laughs)
I think all us moms out there just went, oh my gosh.
Well, give 'em my number,
'cause I'm swinging and single, baby.
(Drew laughs)
That just messed it up.
I just messed it up there just now.
No, no, the show must go on,
if you know what I mean.
Your current show is just phenomenal, "All American,"
and I know that this project really spoke to you.
Can you speak to that?
Sure.
You know, this show was one of those choices for me
where I read the script,
and it really spoke to me,
and I just said yes, and stopped looking
at other projects at the time,
and as soon as I was on set,
that's a lie, the first readthrough,
I knew that this was where I was supposed to be.
You know, there were no names on this project.
It was a bunch of really talented, excited,
you know, passionate kids,
and a few really great adults,
but it was something special,
and it was, you know, one of the few projects
where I'm proud that the subject matter has to deal
with what's going on today, right now,
and, as I said before, I feel lucky
I can discuss, you know, each episode with my son.
You know, some of it's a bit racy,
but I would much rather, you know,
him discuss these issues with me
than, you know, kind of come
to these conclusions on his own, you know,
with Black Lives Matter, and racism, and sex,
and, you know, classism, all this stuff
we deal with on the show,
you know, obviously, with the backdrop of football.
But it's a special project,
and I've had so many great moments with actors
and just with my son because of the show,
and I'm excited for the future.
(lively pop rock music)